dude i got to tell you something
last night on showtimes i saw some
lethal weapon too lethal weapon two
starring the racist ass mellie gibsons
no
i know but i gotta tell you right up
front and truthfully
racist asmelly gibsons is still kind of
my
[Music]
he's still my don't know dog racist
i know i never think about a man
thinking about it remember when he
jacked up all their mutants and the
rogue warriors
talking about this there's nothing in
here but saying yeah
and then remember when he had taken that
hatchet and chopped up all them
england's
remember in the patriot and did it in
front of all his kids you know what
though oh racist-ass melee gibson's is
still my
soul remember when racist says millie
gibson's was blue man group and
braveheart
oh my god it was chopping off my man's
head no no no no no my man was still
talking about the freedom
or what about conspiracy theories though
oh come on what the [ __ ] about
conspiracy theories though
what the f about conspiracy theories
though
what's going on come on you know where
she's that smelly gifts to be directing
to
hell's yeah what about apocalypto yo
racist ass mellie gibson's be telling
the story of a bunch of crazy ass
old-fashioned mexicans who had been in
the jungle getting chased
by a panthers
and what about their passions after
christmas passions of the christ though
passions are passions of the price were
racist as mellie gibson's made that
movie about jesus in a kind of racist
ass way that was all my jams when you
know what i just realized though
what's that you know it would be my what
would be your if racist says mellie
gibson's
co-starred in a movie with jesus are you
talking about
the the savior of all the king of all
kings the alpha and the omega and
jesus that would be
you